I'm going to do a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little
bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit
of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of
a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a
little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little
bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of a little bit of an
little bit of a little bit of a little bit of an little깻 Kingston
Hi, my name's
You
I was muted the entire time. Oh, hey, how's it going? Hello, I was talking this entire time
Hello, hello, welcome in those who
My camp come from my last stream coming from straw knee stream and those straw knee is playing a Skyrim
Vanilla right now, so
Don't feel if you really want to watch that. Holy cool thing. Don't gotta worry
I just like I was thinking like what am I gonna do when I get off and I'm like
I will take me like 15 minutes to do my dishes. So
Might as well just keep going
Yeah, I was insulting you guys for a very long time
Um
Sucks that you couldn't hear how much I was insulting you. I was really really dominant you there
I didn't even pee because I was setting up stream and everything. That's not the pee
Changed my hair to be emo. Yeah, you know, I had to fit the theme of my um the
The fan fiction stream, you know
I'm so sorry you guys missed all that
You pee, you know, there's no it's I don't it's not it's probably not gonna be an endurance stream
I'll probably only stream for like a couple hours
Maybe who knows who knows what's the day monday? Okay, because I'm like, I know I have something to do on wednesday
I have to have to go to a doctor's appointment
Um, so I can't say I'm too late tomorrow night. So
Emo cult mommy, that's me
And the milt hat on
See you in eight hours
No, no, no
Not at all
Let me just make sure everything's working as it should be
Oh
Yeah, I really like it does fit with the theme. Let me uh put on the effects
Yeah, uh, shibany dementia, um
Cotton bum
Cotton way, uh, she is canonically a bunny dillahan who is emo and goth
Oh
My goth alter ego
Where is it
Uh, you're gonna get white woman jumpscare for just a moment
I
Regret that I just realized I skipped
Uh
Orange and I went straight to the water one. No, I really think of it
It's a pretty oh, thank you. Tell my hello. Tell my how are you?
Yeah, I'm feeling pretty pale and gothic
Very white right now
Is it working? I don't know if it's working properly
Okay, yeah, that's cool. All right, hold on. We're back. We're gonna pee and then fall asleep for a second
So
A cold cracking cracking a cold one with the boys accidentally said crapping
Can I wash my hands? No, I live life on the edge
Want to lick and smell my fingers
Oh
All right, we are locked in loaded boys and if you die while I was
Whoa
You're welcome. Why are you wearing a hat?
Oh
Oh, you're starving. Who is this serenity? I can't let serenity starve
Oh, I don't have any food
Okay, I can I can do that because I have the faith for it
Serenity go eat something
And then when their faith those goes down, I'll then I'll do a sermon big brain only if Cheeto dust is involved
I chat froze
It's not like you guys have anything important to say except for toma
Oh
You have important stuff to say debatable
debatable
Do you're not seeing anything of importance right now?
You're all repeating yourselves. All right, fuck that bird
Oh my god, I still have so much shit to do. I just realized I got to make a fertilizer silo
Then I got to make the scarecrow. I don't have enough lumber
Oops, sorry mercy
I have 69 points. Let's get it
Chat cannot cool when I get like the cook the actual cooking station they can cook
No uprising no uprisings in the harem of st. Bum
Not allowed. Why is my head so low? I'm just like peek peeking out
Alrighty, let's go
All right, that's good, that's good
Put some seeds in there
Excuse me
Wow, I didn't burp the last stream did I I remember
Because I just had some seltzer water
I'm trying to clean this
Oh, it's because you were in there. Oh whoopsies
I have to bury you
Goodbye, whatever. Oh Enrique Iglesias
What oh that's somebody said I had to bury to get a cool thing
Well
Oh look you're dead. Oh
I see is dead
Wait, was there I see is dead. No, she's not
Oh, that's just it's a different form of icy
I might use old ic's body for food then
Yeah, it was it was a subtle burp. I wasn't I didn't force it. Um
I'm not even gonna bother making myself any food because there's nothing to eat
All right
Let me make some of these
Cool may make a couple of work on that. All right, let's roll
I'm gonna build us. I'm not fucking building a sleeping bag
All right, so I gotta bring plumber when I have a witness
I forgot to put seeds in the silo. I just remembered
Um sleeping but oh action
See, this is what I mean. Like I have to go back and like fix the tiniest little things
What's up, I see
Mercy's a spy
Mercy where the fuck are you? Mercy, how could you?
Are you spying for another cult?
Hmm mercy sucking up to me guys
Why is why is icy so so, uh, suspectful of uh mercy. I don't know how to feel about that
Okay, I should be able to make a berry bowl now
Look at straw knee hard at work in the fields
Cool
I'm gonna make that for them so that when I leave
Guys can have food
Uh, if I repair that I don't think that'll count as housing the homeless
Demonic hammer
Look at mercy just like, I can't do this right
Yeah, there we go
What hold I see is good telling is awesome. Oh my god all these beds
Now I'm happy enough for that. Do I have enough beds or a bed?
I just want to make sure everything is good before I go
Alrighty
I don't really need to do this room
Didn't know followers could be
He definitely can okay, so let's go in here
Oh, we got that hammer. Oh and my favorite the divine blast
Yes, the gods smile upon me this day shield of faith
That's pretty nice
All right, give me this
This
Bishop heck at those who do not follow the ways the old face be destroyed
Fucking frogs. Oh wait, I forgot how slow this one is
Really time it. There we go. I like that. I can get like two at once though
Oh
At least the frogs are slow don't worry too much
Um, I forget what I can farm here. I can get shells
That new I don't remember getting shells when I play this area before
Oh
Faster night in
And modify dude in
Yeah, it's literally just like the speed of the hammer is
Oh god, oh god. Oh, wow. Oh god. Oh, fuck. Oh, shit. Oh, fuck
Okay, let me run away from that
Wow
Oh, look at the little fucking snail. Oh, oh sweet you guys give me a gun instead
Fuck it. Oh, sorry. I feel bad shooting the snail of it
I know I gotta lead it
I keep aiming wrong what the fuck is wrong with me?
Fuck you
What the hell did that thing just die?
All right
So I started blasting
It's a blunder bus
Sometimes it's hard to like
Aim
Even though I'm like pointing to the side I have to like aim a bunch of times
I just hoping that thing would be closer. Uh, I was I was literally invincible. How the please
I'm I'm aiming at the frog
It's a gift and a curse that one
Money money money money can't move
Did my game just bug out
Did you guys switch something for me? I can't move
Invincible not invisible oh my god, uh
Huh
Oh
Well
Controllers plugged in
God damn it
I
Don't want to quit cuz oh, it's fine
Actually
I can't save
Any one of you guys do me a favor and like try to do something to me
Like try to redeem something that
I know like I feel like what's supposed to happen is
One of the guys shows up
The fuck is that noise
I'll go right it's not any I know it's the game just booked the game just booked. It's not it's just a game
I
Dang it
God damn it, buddy
Uh
It should have
Oh, yeah, it auto it auto save so i'm not worried about that
Um, am I supposed to collect a war from emmy? Where's my little rat gal? There she is
Thanks, emmy
Oh all right
Oh, no, I just I just have to go back through here. It's not a big deal at all. Get the little hedgehog
I
Working as a tendon
Aw man
Now I don't have the uh the divine blast I got a fucking hammer again
At least I see the map
Nice let's go sorry
I
I'm a fire and my laser
Wow
Hello, hello
Oh come in we played a little bit of uh, oh we didn't play anything. What?
Oh, one of you fuckers almost killed me um
We played a little bit of uh
What should i call it?
Oh
We didn't play anything we read some fanfics
Losing my train of thought and um now we are playing some call of the lamb
Um
I'm a bad bitch. You can't kill me. We got crowd control on still in emo mode
Huh
Fuck
Sick
Two people healed me thank you two people
Hold on ah, let me cheekily look and see who
Ah, I see you I know who you are watch your back
Watch your back
That's weird literally I guess I was supposed to just walk through the door
Wait it says who does what effect uh I can see
Sorry I need to pick some cotton
Um
I can see what you guys do as effects
And um crowd control
I've left some uh negative stuff on
But I took off the really annoying ones like just kill me right before a boss
Which somebody did as I was gonna beat a boss. They killed me. It was kind of funny though. Ow. Oh god
Ooh a leafy lantern what I've almost wanted. I bet it does uh
Just goes on surf and talks about how terrible youtubers are
I'm funny
I can't fucking see
Oh
I thought the righteous are death sweet
Oh, I'd rather do it
The best streamer she be is live. I don't know about that. Oh, I didn't mean to press that
Let me get another weapon
I
Find the relic from kudai's clue
I don't I remember when I played the game before I still don't know what the fuck relic they want me to look for
Wait, I didn't mean to press that whatever
Wait, can I talk to them again and maybe they'll tell me again
They're like ice
Relic beast I see she must have seen so though creation because destruction
Hatched as we were in the bosom of the last first gods to bestow godly instruments and yet never wield them ourselves as these are demands
Some place I feel darkness something with me now in the belly of some great beastie
And through their bones laughter
Seek this relic in this place
So
I like how it makes me do it twice
Cheapy noises
Best yeah, I'm the best yapp streamer. I'm the best yapp streamer in all the west. That's for sure
I could talk for literally eight hours. Okay. What the fuck do you want?
Why does the birdie voice speaking remind me of the advisors from raven? Oh, that's right
He sounds like java
Although I think heck it's a girl, which is funny
No, I see
What am I leader had to do in her accent
Oh great everybody's so is it just icy that's starving or is everybody starving
Money
Money money money must be funny
And a rich man's world
Oh
Oh, uh, well here you go
Uh
Awkward, uh, anyways
Yearning for cruel
Is this where the relic is because I said something about eggs
Huh
Hmm
Oh
Pumpkin seed pumpkin seed or rocks wow, hmm hard choice
All right
We continue on
a
New sacrifice
Can't eat cotton
I know my followers are starving
I know
I'm not gonna indoctrinate that
um
Person just yet. I don't really care about that offering statue already got confessional
Need to build all this stuff. What's the hardest to do? Oh
Oh, um, I will go
Offering statue because then they can leave me stuff
Old beans
Yeah, yeah, I know y'all are hungry. I'm working on it
I
Can make you guys all eat shit. Oh fuck. Okay, I need to make more farm plots. That's for sure
Why the fuck you starving? Why you always starving? Hi mercy mercy's a cute little farmer gal
All these berries that I'm getting for you guys wow you guys are gonna eat some real good berry bowls tonight
Um, I mean all of you I only meant some of you
Okay, that should be fine
Okay
Snowberries
Yes, I'm such a great cook
Um, what can I make? I can't do that. I need that
I'm so angry
So
I need to make that
Kind of want to make another refinery
I
Should be fine if I make another refinery
Grab some of that wood let's get that good one
And then I'm gonna make
Of uh, I don't have enough
Okay, and some more plots
I'm needing a scarecrow
I
That's good
How much is a scarecrow?
25 lumber I have 14
I need more lumber
I
See is starving all that
What about oh, I can sell some stuff. I don't really need money right now though
The rest gets girl girl time. I know I like the soundtrack. Uh, I need a fancy stone
So can't even do the offering statue because offering statue actually comes in handy
I'm just gonna do that
Get to it everybody
Hmm
Alrighty
Uh, this will be
This will be uh Zellie
She's a little jellyfish, but I don't have a little she's like a slime. I feel like that fits
That looks too scary
Like a little otter
Yeah, this is cute I like it
She's a skeptic and she's materialistic
Oh variant
I give her spiky hair and I like the circle
Welcome Zellie
Uh, Zellie, I'm gonna have you refine stuff
I have a
A
I have a um should have waited till after I gave a sermon, huh? Um
I'm gonna crustable. I'm going to eat
Me grow stronger
Unquestable like my outfit. Thanks
Sorry mercy don't throw up mercy. No mercy stop
Oh
Oh fasting ritual
Let's do it
Oh
Yeah, it's just peanut butter strawberry jelly boyfriend
All right, mercy give me my money
I
Probably send one of you guys out to get food
Actually
Yeah, I'll send you out to get lumber don't die
It'll be fine
Should I fish a little bit? Yeah
Guess I'm gonna starve
Mercy has condemned us to start. Yeah, you guys you guys can play mercy for that one
Rabbit's foot nice
Well, cool, cool
Divine blast. Thank you very much
All right, cool
No
I believe the hardest where simple force lost it out familiar place
Wow, wow, wow. He only cares for mushrooms his madness crowds
By one we need a ride we release we don't know how to find metaside mushrooms and now we are too afraid to return up to here
If you're to bring can metaside mushrooms. He was over. What do you you find?
The divine blast of Baja
Do it like this
Oh, oh, see that's how you do it. I'm gonna kill all of you guys
Uh, now you don't have to worry about bringing stuff back to him
I just massacred a village itachi chiho style
The bishops my family have they not suffered enough have I not suffered enough because I did voices all day
I'm just not gonna try to strain the way
Hello, probably fine you fought without a vessel we bled we grieved he had the red crown wants more
I see my no more
Okay
Oh, of course you fuckers change the divine blast on me. I knew the moment I said it that somebody was gonna change it
I
Like the phantom one too though, it's not bad. So they attack
Oh
That's hair. Oh, that's right
I'm in my golf phase. I gotta yeah, I got a haircut don't worry about it. Oh
Cool
Very uh sick nasty bro
I
Fuck you. Why did you hurt me?
At least they're like shooting in one direction
At least I have the breakable ones like a lot of stone this way
Hey, I need to go by I need to sell stuff. I need to get more tarot cards
One of my pet peeves is what people call tarot cards tarot cards
Although I get it
Oh, he gave me divine blast back or something else. I don't know what that was
What is the relic I need to
I never completed that last time I played
I looked that up one of you guys can look that up for me. What the relic kudai is asking about
Okay, okay, do you know tarot is not a game
Just so you know don't recommend treating tarot as a game
Because you can do accidentally do some fucked up shit if you do that
There's someone who is knowledgeable about reading tarot cards
Watch 100% get rid of any more relics. I'm gonna go this way. Maybe the relic is over here
Oh
Why did you just I didn't even press anything you just stopped talking
All right
Fuck oh I need more money
God damn it
It's a follower meet because I want to be able to do the thing where we can eat each other
All right, let me just look that up real quick. Yeah, don't treat weija weija
Ouija boards
Weija Ouija
Ouija you're Ouija. Um, it's a cavey that guy because you'll just invite some fucked up shit into your home
What is kudai
Not kudai
Why is a pee
Uh cult
Oh
Okay interesting
Uh, yes, I actually I can read tarot. Um, I liked doing tarot card readings
When I was a priestess in another life, I did a lot of occult stuff. I did a lot of occult research for people. I um
Uh
Like I did like the pagan
Pagan roots of like holidays every time there was a holiday. I did a video on it. They'll just I mean stream on it
It's really fun
I'll probably only do that though
When I do it with emmy because I just feel like I wouldn't fit my content if I did it
I'm also like that's any content. There's a lot of reasons why people thought I was gonna be emmy because she was the occult one
I'll give me some rocks
Yeah, tarot's before yes, uh, come on. No, Sarah as well. Yeah, one day. Maybe a collab with emmy
I remember tarot in a while
The last time I remember tarot for myself was before I got accepted into Bueller
I
I will always die to these things no matter what
There was a way to be like spawning that type of monster you would guys would just fuck me the entire time
Um how to fate super no, I don't know. I kind of like my
My area of attack one when I go back to the other one
Tarot like most of these were occult stuff in the west
French tarot, uh, I feel like
I've never heard of french tarot to be honest with you unless it's just like in french culture to use tarot like the
because the writer, writer waits tarot
To use that for
Just like every day because some people just like do stuff in their day to day just to um
It's like predictions like or just for advice. So I wouldn't be surprised if like the fucking french do that
It sounds like a french thing to do
Yeah, I know where your fucking relic is nobody just you wait
Yeah
Tarot is you know, it's linked to it is mostly used for the occult and I think in western cultures. Oh fuck me
um
Uh, but also in like
I feel like a lot of like native cultures
Tarot is used as a divination tool
Um, I when I would do streaming with tarot
I would usually just recommend if you didn't believe in it or you feel comfortable with it
You can use it as a reflection or introspection tool
That would be the little oh those cards. Yeah, I've not used those cards before
Because I'm always like you can do you don't have to believe in what it is. We can just have fun
See what it has to say and then 99 percent of the time
If not a hundred
Um
I was oh fuck me
Right about whatever they were going through
All right, oh you're gonna you're gonna be a bitch to fight aren't you?
Oh my god, oh, I wish I had the dagger
Oh my god
What are you
Oh
Why is this so difficult? Oh, I have a gun
Like what just happened? Oh god, how am I supposed to dodge that am I supposed to dodge roll through it?
Because I don't know if I can do that
Oh
My god
Wait, how am I not dead yet? Do you guys do something that I can't die?
You can roll through it. Oh, you know, I never knew that
Uh, thank you chat for constantly killing me
My dumb ass like I'm like am I good at this game or is like something glitching
But no my chat has been really nice
Thank you harem keeping me alive
Oh
Sorry controls crowd control just fucking froze
Ah
Think it's good weird. Okay. I was looking and just like decided to be weird. What am I doing?
And I like you you always give me a blunder bus
Thank you
Get a reward. Okay. What would you like as a reward for being healed?
I'll let you talk amongst yourselves
And decide
A kiss kiss 100 you think I got a hundred dollars again
Sandwich
Wonder bussy
Like I need bars for something I don't know what I need gold bars for but I know I do
Do
I want a sandwich like how am I supposed to get you a sandwich
Zellie no, why are you spreading false hoods?
Zellie
We're going to jail
Oh
She looks so sad
All right, uh, oh you want a turkey sandwich
How do I make you a sandwich I can't make sandwiches in this game
All right
Oh hell yeah a sandwich like codeword for something jumping jacks. I'll just hear my my boobies slap
I don't know what it's like
I
Oh, they're starving they don't need that
A meat feast was you sir emo or emo because we were playing we were sorry we're not playing we were
Reading my immortal the best fanfiction of all time
I
Find from the pub thingy, I don't know when I'll be able to unlock that
um
death
Can we eat people?
Uh
We are cannibals
Wow
Feast upon me
You're like, oh, okay up down a clown
These guys keep pooping everywhere
Lovely, lovely
We love to see it
Why do they all look why do you guys look sad because you can eat people
Ah so fast
I need to get another oh shit, um
I
Lumber thing fuck you bird
If I can make a confession booth wait, hold on let me see what else I can make before I just make a confession booth
Uh, okay, okay, I don't need to make another silo. I can't make another that
So yeah, I guess I'll make uh one of these
confession booths will be behind
The church
Cool beans got to step in everybody
Some shit in here
Hi, I see give me one second. Why are you so angry?
Leader mercy continues to masquerade as a faithful something must be done. You need to imprison them
All right, because I need the faith mercy. I'm sorry. You got to go to prison
Ah
Wait, can I re-educate you before you go?
No, okay, I can murder zele, but I don't want to do that
Mercy in here
She working with serenity a mere mercy. I'm so sorry
But you got to go to jail
But it's fine because then I'll just release you
Oh
And then where the hell did I see you go? Oh, let me let me
I might have to get the propaganda thing
I see are you working in the mines?
Thank you for keeping me home and do her voice
Thank you for keeping us safe later
That's the best I could do
Faith up stones ready to bone
May do some more go bars. We'll do some more of these
Just so I can stock up
All right
It's getting to be nighttime. No, I don't need to talk to you. I'm just positive some seeds. Oh, I don't have any beetroot seeds
Not cool
Oh, I didn't get any seeds or that I have to buy of seeds
Uh, I don't really need cotton because we're not eating cotton in this place
I
Still don't need to eat food. I'm gonna go
fishing
Now I see what the goofy of voice
Well, I can replicate her accent is just getting the pitch right
In her cadence because she tends to draw out her
Her words like she's constantly thinking
I could see the liver being pretty good muscle tissue. I feel like it suits up
Uh, uh, there's a cat. Okay, hold on me. Bye
This that's why I came over here to buy these
Have fun. Thanks for stopping by
Oh
She be gone fishing
Oh, I can probably go see that dude. I got stuff to do I gotta walk around
Sometimes I think about if she'd be an hour in high school
She protect me from bullies and let me call me dork and share her biscuits with me and take me to prom and make me practice kissing
Oh, I didn't mean to leave
I know you're British because he said biscuits
That's all I needed to do I don't have any money to buy these
Uh
These parasocial chatter you're wrong about that
No, they meant actual bread biscuits with jam and stuff because I'm like I like big biscuits. I like Popeyes biscuits
Outing my affliction. I've been afflicted with British
Oh
So hungry some mushrooms I found woke up three days later with the worst headache, but I kind of want more
That's crazy. Um
Hey
Greetings traveler me why I'm so so of course researcher of all things mushrooms. I'm a shroomhead
Just a little joke so so likes to tell
Yes, yes mushrooms mushrooms are so's as passion. I saw some needs more
Okay
I just
Here you go
I killed your followers for this
Oh, thanks
I don't know why you have that but cool doctor. I went to a con. I think I contracted British
A lot of follower forms
Oh, like the camera panned up in a really weird way that's something was gonna happen
Okay, and now I need to go down to the dog. Is there a cure?
Moving to America
Is that a fucking croc?
All right, three projectiles. Do you have no tarot cards for two projectiles? That's pretty sick actually
It's a fucking croc
Are you guys doing?
Oh, I'm like, huh a little axolotl dude
I wonder if they're all axolotls because I'm like I have a bunch of crystal shards
Blah, blah, blah
50% off
harvest bone free. Oh fuck
Oh, man, I literally have no fucking money. Can I sell you stuff? Oh
Still haven't caught a squid yet
Hold on. What did you want me to say? I feel like is that a bad word?
What does that mean? Oh, shit. What the hell?
This catching relics left and right
My controller won't start vibrating. You know what that means
Yeah, it doesn't yeah, it's all right. Can it stop? Okay. Thank god. Let it broke
It's a type of bread
Fire the potato is that bad?
I feel like I just said something bad
No, it's just tasty. No bad. Okay
What's up with my model genuinely curious, uh, we were we were reading my immortal
We're in the main character is like emo and she's gothic. So I got a little gothic outfit and I changed my hair color
And then my neck detaches because
This is my goth form
Oh
Fuck come on. There we go. Finally
Take the fucking pussy
Dussy
Oh, yeah, I'm part uh this form is part dull hand anytime. I change my outfit and it's it's
It's my dull hand counterpart
Oh, thanks
Spooky
Not bad
Not bad at all. You're a pro at the pole
You stalked me up nice and good if you find the fish and scarce. I'll sell them
Cool. Can you sell them for me? Oh, no
What are you buying? What are you selling?
All right, we did that we did that we did that
She described herself in every chapter still for gorg
I I did spend a very long time designing like trying to fix the transparency and coloring everything
It's fucking random flower thing
Okay, um, I need to do this
Lovely lovely
I love this game so much
That's soon enough I can get a little fire
I
Gotta re-educate selly what are you selling?
Damn it. You're still sorry. Sorry kid
All right
What can I build
I need 20 wood. I doubt there's 20 wood in here. God fucking damn it. Oh golden poop
Oh sweet money can I oh, oh I have to bury it at night
Oh
Aren't you the cutest what does that mean penitence? Whoa, what the fuck?
That's cool
Oh
Nice his name is Weber. He just fucking knocked out
All right, this will be
Misma
I spilled our name, right
And there's more rising
Okay, I did
And let's see she's like she's kind of a badass bitch
I don't know if any of these like fit her I feel like
I
Looks like don't starve club
Oh, that's what that stuff is. It's don't starve related. Uh, what the fuck is that?
It's like fucking Chuck E cheese
Um
I'll make her a little fox because she's a foxy mama
No, and I'll make her a gray fox
She's a germaphobe and she's faithless
Give her a little bayang she got the bayang
Um, you can farm I suppose okay
You need to get those deposit things ASAP
I
Germaphobe ah it's fucking took a flower get back here you son of a bitch
Come here. Come here. Fuck her. Okay. Well, I'd rather clean this up get money for golden shit
I think it's icy that like shit's gold, which is funny or like scrawny. It's one of the girls
I see always need something late leader mercy will not give up their games if you must take care of them permanently step
No, I'm not gonna kill mercy
I see stop trying to get me to kill mercy
Goddamn
All right
Got my beetroot put that all in there some berries cool cool cool
Uh, again a little a way a bit hungry so I can put in
What is that such as beads beads beads? Okay
Oh
Oh nice so I can just make food out of this now
Yep
Yeah
Enjoy
All right, Zellie are you gonna be good?
Do I have I need to make another
Oh might dig up these plants
Just so I can make another lumber because I know it's gonna fucking go
Yeah, I see some the villain arc you think it'd be like uh, mercy would be the one they're like
They're a spy and like trying to gaslight everybody, you know
I see the yandere and only wants the college you think that'd be mercy right now I can make another lumber
I
Don't like how this isn't okay, it isn't even
So I can there we are cooking with gas
Nice um can I make this thing now
I need which I don't have any money. Okay. Well, fuck me then
That's um, I don't want to throw some golden shit in there
Go go go wow we are we're we're jamming at least fucking birds. How do I I need how much
Ah
Okay, we're gonna face only do that what does this work take you for confession
Wow, I can't believe you tried sucking your own dick that's wild
Okay, seems like everything we're doing pretty good. We're doing pretty great. I'm pretty proud of us. Uh, let me
That
I don't have enough wood for other stuff and I can't make gold
It's fine. It's fine
Sorry, didn't mean to talk to you. I meant to clean this
Cause you guys just poop everywhere
Wonder happens if I eat mince follower meat
Now say I'm I'm fine. I don't need it
That was a secret. Well, sorry shouldn't have told me
Die die die die die die. I can't kill you
All right. Well, what is that little piggy? Give me I just want the spiders. I just want to eat them
I'm gonna kill heck it
I might like make a PB and J
I
Feel a little bit homey. All right. All right. All right. What's up?
Oh
Oh my god, fuck you. Fuck you. Fuck you. Fuck you. Oh, what the hell?
Oh, I hate that these little things just like fly outside of
The fighting area or you can knock them outside and then they just come out of nowhere and hit you again
If you're not tracking them
Then you just have an accord. Yeah, but the encrustables are small and I want like an actual PB and J
Some brave and PB and J's
I need wood. I need maybe I should just go to dark wood and then I can get an eye for that, dude
What the hell
Oh, those things don't get destroyed they just get bounced off
So, uh, how do I do that?
Oh, I can't do it because I don't have things
Uh, are you guys all having shields? You are except for this guy. Um
I can't
Oh
My god, I'm literally gonna just fucking die because I keep bouncing off of everything can't see
I need to start giving gifts to you guys
Her body is missing that turns PB and J to gap. I've only had like a what are you today?
Actually, no, I I made myself a salmon and rice for lunch
but that was like
Oh, fuck me
What did you guys just do?
Excuse me
Hey, what the fuck just happened?
Am I am I hearing voices
I
Could have sworn I heard someone do a don't know if that's so fucking weird
But it was like I'm going crazy
They burped oh
You get the voices you maybe
Maybe I hear the voices
Um
Cool be good be good in the hood
Wait, nope not these I can make into trees
Make into trees
Oh this fucking guy oh dice
Oh
Beans
Stonehenge were in your walls not weird were
Uh
Seems like I'm supposed to go here probably to interact with somebody
Oh, no three grapes
Oh, baby we get in grapes. I don't remember there being grapes
Oh, baby because it's part of the sins of the flesh and I think you can make like wine and drinks and stuff from it
I
Why do I feel like I'm hearing a voice of my headphones am I I'm going insane
See in crossables talking to me
Sorry, I just looked out my window and there's like a little bit of an incline on the road in front of um
In front of my apartment and there is a father outside
Pushing his kids in a stroller
And then he lets them go down the hill and he runs behind and then he runs forward to push it
He's like doing a workout with his kids in the stroller and I was his all I saw was a stroller going backwards towards the road
It's not a busy road, but I was like what the fuck
That's terrifying me
We're about to be debauchers debauchers darling
That is the voice maybe
There's really no point of me being here
You see Feliz Navidad
All right
Oh so bad for you
Yeah, just it just threw me off
Can I can I please get some wood
Can I please get some wood?
Can I please get a waffle
Oh
Come over here
Yeah
Sometimes there's so much that's happening on screen. I don't know what the fuck I'm doing. What the hell? I was
Oh
Sisyphus prime and my nose adopted gerbil's pet what I have no idea what you're talking about. Okay. I don't like this one
Oh now I understand
Because I'm like Sisyphus and I'm like, oh, yes the greek
Myth yes, of course
Um, I would rather have the death sweep
Just because although I could have gone the night, but I just don't like that. This was kind of bothering me
Ah
Hey, what's up heck it
Cannot be allowed
All this most damning absence the retribution must be snowed painful cast effect the fuck
I literally they were just starving
They were just starving. Why did you have to do it again?
Uh, I could get the dagger. I'd actually think I would prefer the dagger
It's faster
Yeah, I found your thingy. What do I get now?
It's famine time
Do I chop it
Is there something I do it because I don't want to piss off this tree. It's bleeding
Oh
Okay
I definitely needed the lumber but I feel kind of bad because I had a face
I don't do anything with a face
Hello famine my old friend. You've taken all my potatoes again
I
A lot going on
Oh
Yeah
We did it. Yeah, I see mo we did it
Pumpkin golden nugget. I don't know what the I got I got pumpkin something with that so
I just peed and I feel like I got peed
One elephant died got him
We're taking better care of her that she takes care of listen
It's not my fault an old ancient god of the old faith made you all starve. All right
I'm about to make you some good food
I like watch, you know
Oh because I looted a corpse because I looted ic score. Well, I can't do anything with it
I was gonna we're gonna eat old ic but it's not working out. Did you live?
Oh my god, okay, you're fucking dead. Thanks for nothing
Well, we're gonna eat you
Delicious wow
Don't worry guys
Everything's gonna be fine
Got some minced follower meat
Is there a poop eating trait
You
We were gonna eat ic but it doesn't seem like it's gonna happen fucking birds
I don't know what my cats are doing it's tent in the fields
Getting some cotton
I
Have to make another bed before I can doctor neat that one
Meat meat meat. Well, we're vegetarians mostly it seems unless
Do I not have enough beds? Why are you sleeping over there? I know I have enough beds
What are you doing what is like jumping into a bag
Oh
My god, Zellie
Hold on I need to handle this one. This is the second time Zellie
And I got to put you in prison it's always a little cute funny ones
Listen, I know you're mad. I'm currently getting you guys food. So you need to relax
Oh
Their bed breaks it doesn't auto reassign all doesn't it usually they just go
Okay, we got some of that got some cauliflower. We got pumpkins. We got beetroot. Oh, okay
Like you guys some more food
Yeah, they're probably gonna have to poop
We're cannibals in this house
I don't have any fucking lumber
Oh great, I'm so happy that I
Filled that it was gonna break
Oh, you guys are so like hard to maintain
I need to make
I think I can I'm gonna do one of these
Oh
See you guys are no longer starving
I'm not meaning to walk in there. I forget that I can get demons
Hell yeah cannibalism all right you
Are gonna go out and not die and you're gonna get some lumber
You got this I believe in you so much
What is up
I'm not I already have no faith so it doesn't matter
Can't be negative faith
Cannibalism rocks
Oh, let me do that. Uh, let's see. Let's see
Um
weapon mastery
Oh
Because then that does like ice and shit
Yeah, I'll do the curse of the tundra
What does this do really righteous?
There's no curse
Okay, so I can get five or again. Oh, yeah, I'll do that that actually
It's very efficient like when you're out of food it's important that you can eat some people
We're doing so good look at all these faithful people hold on actually come back here
Um
We're gonna do I don't have enough wood. Okay, what if you guys have to die?
I am so sorry
I can't kill Azura. Oh fuck. I can't kill any of the girls. I'm so sorry
But it's time for you to go
Farewell
Thank you for your sacrifice
Yeah, now you can make some more food that's great
Strony, don't worry about me killing people. It's it's fine. Don't worry about it.
Holy crap
Big ass poopy, which of you guys took a giant ass dump?
All right, thank you for your sacrifice this will not be in vain
All right. All right. All right. Oh
There'll be shit
Everybody's so pissed off
I might yeah, I can't make
I need this I need more lumber
So
Okay, um
People will probably be fucking faithless tomorrow and leave and steal my money
I didn't mean to do that
I literally just need lumber that's all I need in this world
I really don't feel like going to dark wood. I don't know if that should just let the tree grow
Uh, yeah, there's really nothing I can do to
Zero what do you gotta say?
Damn you try to suck your own titties sometimes when you're really thirsty you just you just live off of that. That's impressive
And I level you up
Oh
Go around giving gifts you just get to get strong
Okay, let me
Can I give emmy a necklace?
I can ask her I can give her be like give me your money. I'm gonna make it so she doesn't need to sleep
You loving everybody up
All right
Okay, Zipar you're going to be uh
I don't know how to thank you
Oh
She's kind of a demonic badly
So
Give her this cute little form
That color works he's sickly and she's gullible
What happened
I
Really cute
Okay
What's with the new model it's not new we're just in a golf form
You'll like what you see
We're just uh, we're just emo today because of um, oh what should I make you do?
I'm sure he's we can turn on the beds. Oh fuck. Okay, that's a little bit
Oh
Can I eat this live omelet?
Oh, oh, but it helped. Oh fun
Okay, hold on me. Oh, she's already been reeducated
Do a grand shelter perhaps
I'm position two. Ooh, that actually might be helpful though
Composed you throw the bodies in a lot of you guys haven't died yet. So that works out
So I don't really need to worry about a crypt
I think I'm gonna do this
Oh
It works and it works I had I enabled dark mode. Yeah, just to set the mood
All right
Can you guys get get lumber please? It's not enough beds
Okay, I have three
All right, please not let me fuck this up
They're not beds. No, they're still not enough beds
I am killing this tree. Give me three. Give me three or I will riot
No, I am rioting. What's up, Emmy?
I
Would love some of the flowers some dark red dungeon
I need to go there anyways. I need to get wood
And what the sigma discovered what that word was the other day
Okay, is there any other trees around okay this one
It took me yeah, it was fun playing with it. It just took a long time to do
Yay, okay
Ah so fast still not enough beds
All right, maybe this one to really let these grow but I don't
Don't need them to be more faithless than they already are
All right probably yep, okay perfect perfect perfect
I guess yes, I do have to fucking assign all these beds. Why is there two azuras?
Did you guys resurrect Azura might sacrifice one of them
Emmy lives here mercy you can sleep there
Wait who doesn't have a bed
Oh
Weber where are you going to sleep?
Okay, Weber sleeping there
I
Can go Amy doesn't need a bed because she doesn't sleep but
Amy's working in the mines chat the children
They yearn for the mines
Okay, are we good? I feel like everybody has a fucking bed
I just repaired that oh my fucking god you guys are the worst
Two goat moms well makes it's like her it's the peace that she set to be with her family her god family
Okay, people can go eat and I'll do a little sermon and then I'll go for a run
The beds can't handle it hasn't even been the sex sex part yet
I'm pretty sure the weapons scale with the monsters so I don't even know why
Offer that
Holy wow
Fun
I
Like how it didn't let me didn't show up the thing yet. Okay, so he did
Suscendence
Hmm see you after life
Uh well you guys already resurrect people anyways
So I'll just do the funeral one then
The sheer presence of two is there this is too much
Cool now we can have funerals ain't that cute
Does I be killing a lot of you fuckers
I don't like I don't like seeing the thing
Oh my god we're getting our own coffins like ebony. Hi everybody's happy
Can you take a confession? Uh
Uh
Take mercy
You didn't want to his body
Oh, okay, I guess it doesn't make it that bad if you cleaned it afterwards cool
Now I'm actually let me give mercy a gift
Oh
The bar is floating in front of my face. All right later nerd. I was kidding. I would not call mercy a nerd. She is
sweetest
We are living off of beetroot
I don't have any cauliflower
Oh shit I think it's huge
Hello, what's going on? We're playing cult of the stardew valley
Sure beats starving. Haha. Good one. Look at him about to give you guys delicious food
And all cheery cauliflower chowder
Nice it's cheery
Oh, I'm gonna eat this one and I eat it. No, it's not letting me eat it. All right. Well
I'll eat this one
He's gonna make this shamanade pink
Which money do I have actually I'm gonna go buy some I'm gonna sell some stuff and buy some tarot cards
What is the most expensive
I always go fishing again
Okay
She actually made us good see I take care of of all my children
All right, let's get some cards. Want the bonus resources?
This one
Fire projectile image during the day
Uh, I do have money for all of them. I'll just get all of them
Actually, let me check the other place first
I
Realize they mostly do my runs at night, so I'm not gonna buy the sun one right now
Okay, then we'll go to this guy
What are you buying what are you selling?
Um
What was the one over here?
Soul snatcher
That one
See how he's doing for that
I
Cards spawn a tentacle
Night one
Oh
20 I got left I got 47 uh rolling into an enemy you'll damage them damages
I'll do that
Oh
Coolio all right, excuse me mushroom dude
Hey, it is a good song
Oh
I was saying like the what do you buy it because I was watching I've been watching gamecrumbs play through um
resident evil
Eight and the duke was like making the reference to resident evil floor going what do you buy it?
And I was just like
Okay, uh
Some of you guys might get sick. It's fine though. Don't worry about it late 5% chance
Great
Okay, we're gonna go darkwood
Sorry I'm more so focusing on
Building stuff and building resources
I'll probably play a little bit of this off stream when I say a little I'll probably end up like beating two bosses
Oh, hey
Oh, it's uh, Voldemort was kidding around us the world creaks and turns before it stood immobile motionless sentries go frost
Oh
Unless she has fallen hair upon the inhabitant of the sand together fight to new to presume power
You shall not find them so easily dispatched again
Ah fun
My least favorite combo
Or would rock was young what?
Ah
Right
It's time to pop up
Oh
I'll come back a friend. Oh, oh my gosh. Oh, yes. Oh perfect. Hi
Freddy
Hi, shimmy. It's me again fun time Freddy and welcome to the cult of the lamb. Well, I'm here. See what happens next
Let's find out and see
I love it
I love it so much
I'm gonna make a pb and j real quick
You guys can hear me talk
Hello
How does it get crowded like
I don't even think that's your thing
There's paint on bottom here
Okay, I hope my brother's a pony
He are safe
I toast the bread
Usually I toast my breath around pb and j's
then
We're super human in old school
That one does
Right
I'm being surrounded by cats
I'm thinking I beat a cat heck it
Um
I'm getting a wave at 8 3
Moving into peanut butter and can't eat it
Catch crab with light
What's that? Oh no
No, it's not good pb and j though or is the sandwich in general unless you cut it diagonally
It's a diagonal
I don't even know if you guys can hear me
I
Prefer raspberry preserves
Bounds of tartness and speed
But if there's no raspberry preserves, I will just get strawberry jam
I really don't like grape jump or create flavor thing
I
Don't think you like grape kind of like is that honest kids grape juice
Doesn't taste like okay, I could later for pre-sum
I'm not a grape soda kind of gal either
I
Whoa that emo red riding hood
Precisely
It's not a phase chat it's not a phase
I'm eating pb and j
Okay, everyone settle down settle down
I don't want you guys to get crazy and wild
But please don't spoil the cult the lambs story. I don't want the story to get spoiled. Okay, you got it freddie
No spoilers here
Um, it's a phase connect. Um, it is whole green bread
It's a lifestyle
There's a story to the game totally
It's the the gods and the cult. Yep
Yeah, it's like the like 10 seed whole grain
How you guys doing
Hanging in there while you're starving and stuff
Yeah, tag your spoilers guys
I
Hang it on cool. I'm doing good
Be honest with you, I haven't been really that productive lately besides like streaming related stuff
So i'm like i'm trying to
Think tomorrow i'm on my goal to be like to do like three productive things, you know, it's my head flies away
I
So i'm like, okay
Mostly as i'm like, maybe I just do just clean. I like cleaning. Cleaning's relaxing
So I really just gotta do the dishes. That's all i'm only gonna do
Um, i'm like, uh, you know, i've been putting it off going food shopping, but I need to do it
Need to go food shopping. I can't keep door dashing forever. So that would be the dream
I
Need a bar in july before bed naughty or
What
mods
Slap his ass
And tell him i'm his daddy
Thank you
Instacart not like I need to leave my house like I definitely need to leave
My house
I haven't oh, I need to text my parents. I haven't talked to my parents in a long time. Well, not a long time
I need to text my parents as an update from yesterday
So i haven't texted them and talked to them since yesterday
Remember I get plenty of food to imagine maybe i'll go and i'll
I didn't I didn't go and see my dad. So like maybe I should go and see my dad
Although he's out of the hospital, but no
Because usually the last time it's happened he was there for like two days
But they usually kind of got down to a science what they got to do for him
Stand up and be your own mom
Now my mods mods are locked in they there
To live far not too far
Not too far
But uh, yeah
Yeah, just just a weird thing that happens to him sometimes
But um
Who's it called what tactic are you something cardio
Inflation around the heart i'm like blinking because i'm tired
Around the heart sack
Our carditis thank you. I'm like they're a cardium. I'm like that's the lining but what's the what's the thing
Mom's take his reactions. No, he's good. He's good
Although like I said, I haven't heard from them since yesterday, but
Again, usually only takes like a day or two for him to leave. So I'm just assuming that to be honest with you
I could be a really shitty daughter sometimes
And they'll stay up
They call my grandparents
Like yeah, how are you? I'm like, uh
I'm all right
I'm just like I just don't like talking to people
If we don't we're gonna cover this over. Yeah
It's like I just I tend to overreact for stuff because I'm a very emotional person
And that's why my mom tries to like tell me stuff and like let's me down easy
Whatever the the thing is
Um, she's just like I don't want you to panic because I'm like
I just tend I'm just like very worried very attached to my mom and my dad
Being the only child and shit, but actually let me text
So
You know, it's really funny know how I told you guys that my
Extra cat because you're supposed to only have two
I said like the whole cat setting thing and they haven't even responded to me. I'm like
So you threaten me and then you wait like a couple days to like tell me if I need to make any adjustments to my friend or anything
Like what the fuck
Come on
Let's be real
All right, well, you'll see you you'll see if you ask my mom is still say
What's that thing where you're like or where like you overreact a lot stuff? Is it like hysterics your hysterics?
When you overreact to stuff
Yeah
It's a Hispanic man this google ai thing is so fucking stupid. What is the word?
It's not has not hypochondriac. It's not hysterical. It's a personality type personality
type where
You over
React not overreach
No, it's not borderline personality disorder
Okay, I give up
Starts with an age. It's not hysterical. It's like his something
I'm just I'm just gonna
Oh
I
Histronic thank you
Magical minty hypochondria. What is that?
Hystronics hystronics. Yes. What is the
Exaggerate oh wait, no, let's to attract attention
Right, am I done?
I don't do it for attention. I'm just an overreactor
Hyperbolic
I
He's good. He's good. We're doing okay
My mom's hanging in there. Probably when I'll tell them in person. I'll tell them
About your guys is
Really awesome support. I think my parents would be like
Cool, okay, let me put my headphones back on
King cats
I'm just so happy to be here that I
Like I have a tendency to like isolate and shit
Sometimes I just need to talk to my parents
Sometimes I need to talk to you guys
It is in fact, oh, it's a personality interesting fascinating
Real fascinating
As my chat froze let me fix that
There we go
Yeah, to them like a chapter. Uh, my mom yaps more than I do
But only if she really likes you otherwise she doesn't she won't talk at all
Like she'll just like listen and just like
She'd be like, can I trust this motherfucker?
Are you a real motherfucker? Can I trust you and then she'll like listen to you talk watch your behavior then she'll decide
Me I just talk talk talk talk talk talk and me and my dad
We just go
Please like us. We're gonna. Yeah, we're gonna try to do everything in our power to gap enough for you to like us
My mom's just like I don't fucking know but then when you get her going
Especially about birds
Or or gardening. She's there
She's having a great time
In cult of the lamb you must defeat all the bosses on your path and what you're there
You might confront the one who weighs what?
Freddy no spoilers
Freddy
Goodness gracious ready
My tracking is not that good because I'm in the dark
You know what is a show? Oh, I'm sorry. No a movie. I haven't seen her favorite flower. Um
Dahlia to Dahlia
Then she likes peonies
Although it was really funny because when she first started gardening she's called them peonies and I'm like mom
It's called a peony. She's like a peony. I'm like peony
She likes yeah, she likes Dahlia's and uh peonies
And then
My what's my dad's favorite flower?
It's not foxglove
I think my dad's just like
I'd probably say like the shrubs that we we helped pull out. He'd be like, yeah, I did that one. That's that's the one I like
No, it's not pronounced peony
It was really cool though. I got to help her plant Dahlia's
um
She's been working on like like a vegetable garden and just like
You know, like when you hear someone just be like super passionate
We'll something they oh
I thought mercy died. I was really nervous. Um, super passionate about something
I
Love this like listening to my mom
Yeah, and her eyes light up when she talks about like making her vegetable garden
And like all the stuff she's gonna cook with it and it just makes me so happy
She is doing something that she loves and like that's like what v-tubing is for me, but I kind of wish I also had
What the hell
Um
But I wish I had
Like another hobby
Like maybe like an outdoors one
Or like a more active one because like it was really cool doing jujitsu, but after
I got like could like having fibro and stuff and they're on fire this in my neck. Although I'm like
fucking young at age 56. Um
I just I couldn't do it anymore because it was just painful
It was such a good full body workout
And it's usually what happens to people like I got injured and I can't train
It was cool though, I went to my old school and I watched people get um promoted to belts
I'm like wow, they'll never be me
It is like I hadn't been so passionate about something
So sucks when the source things happens
Uh, I was Brazilian jujitsu
I
There's this one dude, um, you remember how I told you that I accidentally put one of my um
Like spar sparring partners to sleep so
Mind you he didn't tap like if it was if he tapped
Then
I wouldn't have I would have let up, you know
He never tapped he just like went to sleep and it's not like he didn't couldn't tap
He could have easily tapped
But um, so his friend
His friend, um
Bumi what are you saying?
Put me in a
Uh
To lock and just fucking cranked my ankle
And he was like and then I had to tap during our our spar and it fucking hurt so bad
My ankle was swollen
He's like that was putting putting that kid to sleep
And I'm like you're a fucking piece of shit. You're lucky that you're better than me or I put you in the ground
Um because he was a blue belt
And I also fucking hated him because every time I rolled with him you just smelled like fucking cum
I'm like who sweats and they smell like this. It's like so gross
And at that time I was the only girl in my class because the the girls they used to I used to train with stopped going and I was like, come on
Like I can put you I can probably put like an unexperienced person in a holds
um
like I remember um
Salem one of my best friends, um, she
I was like showing her some moves and so I put her in a rear naked chokehold in the middle of our store
In a retail store that we worked at and she just let out the like the most like
The most cute and funny scream because she's a high-pitched voice. She was like
Like she sounded like fucking r2d2
It was so funny
And um
Come here squirrel
So like for her it was it was easy. Oh sweet. I think it would um, let's see
I don't know
This way because I think we have what a second time
This is french perfume, but like I had never
Experienced that because like being in gym class with people from school
um
Like or the other guys that I would roll with I'm just like why the fuck do you smell like
Nutt
Like that's so fucking gross
Like
Like like you know how like people have like pheromones
And stuff and like sometimes when you sweat you smell good
Like
I've had people certain people tell me like I um
When I sweat I smell good. I remember like reading that right now. What are you doing?
She's like on my lap that if you like have something that's like someone's like sweating and they smell good to you
you're like
You know, you're like genetically pre-disposed to want to like be with them or something
Uh, it was a mix of gi and no gi
Um, we were doing that when I was rolling with them, then we were we were doing um
I don't know if it was up
We were doing a gi and we were trying a collar
Collar submissions
My favorite was
Doing a bow and arrow choke
You start the last time
I got the money for it. We're not
You
Don't think you feel like dislikes anyone sweat smell. Well, that means that you know, I guess you're genetically pre-disposed like those people
Someone if you means like I think it's like I remember reading that like if someone smells good to you that
You would have you would have it's because they're like genetically
healthy
To your mind and you want to
appropriate with them
Some creates strong babies very like
Basic instincts come here bird
Yeah, something to do the microbiome immune system. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Like it's like, oh, I if you smell bad
You like must be sickly or like you're just disgusting
Forgive me. She forgive me. She be chat. I accidentally spoiled the story. That was very not cool
I said too much. I'm sorry. Don't want to spoil it again. No more spoilers. No, it's all right, freddy
We forgive you freddy. Don't worry about it. I'm as happy you're here freddy
Oh, it explains a lot my teacher demonstrated it bow and bow and arrow on me and this is so it's so fun to do
I just drive my fucking knees into the person's back
To create a large brood
Yes, a large brood
Oh, it's not really I need like one more flower thing
I
Am I here rain and plowing because she's right next to the mic. Oh, hello
Will
So I started blasting. I think I'm fine. I think I'm good
Oh
Yeah
Yeah, I think for me smell is like a
Very big thing to me because of big your breath smells. I don't want you anywhere near me
You got the helitosis stay the walk away from me bud
Like I remember having customers and like such like I had one guy that I could smell his breath
from like
Five feet away. It was bad out
I think didn't go off
Like helped you get into dumb of nature it really did though because like
It was a really good like if
I always recommend if you like have anger issues or something
Going to the gym or like doing a contact sport
Is so
satisfying
because I would like
I would just be like so
angry and pent up and like fucking depressed and then
I would just go and beat up dudes like it was so great. It was so awesome
I
Was just super satisfied and it also was just like super
Empowering in a way because like I knew I like if course came just
Fucking rain. I just stepped on my nipple. Holy shit. Oh my god claw just
Essentially just pierced my nipple
Oh
Oh, not you guys
Especially mixed with the fucking bats
What's why did you have to spawn more?
Uh, I was not paying attention. Oh, fuck me
Thanks guys accidents do happen a lot. I'm just gonna let the story narrate itself. See you guys later. Bye freddy
Stay fun time
Yeah, it's just like you're just like a good type of tired
after
Um doing jiu-jitsu
Because one I like I like jiu-jitsu because it was I was almost like fucking
Being in the military because he got into practice like discipline and respect
Um with restraint
Oh, let's see how they are doing. I kind of want to get a grand shelter
I'm gonna get this fucking propaganda speakers. I'm gonna get a grand shelter. Oh, wait, no, I want to do the one that
I
Although like I remember like my dad was trying to teach me how to deadlifts because my dad deadlifts um
And that was pretty cool, too. Like it was super satisfying. I only did it like once though because it wasn't
As satisfying as like laying a sport was
Yeah, you are best get real close and comfortable
Also, I don't know if it's the same in the u.s. But my gym was such an inclusive sport
Yeah, like 100 it really was because I
It because I could tell like some of the guys would hold back when they um sparred with me
I'm gonna buy you now. Yes, fucking. Thank you. Oh my god. Thank you so much go to sleep
Go to sleep
Um
I
Um, but yeah, oh as I was saying, um, oh my god, I'm gonna talk that up
I would say like how am I gonna learn if you you know
Don't give the same like how am I? Oh my god. How am I gonna defend might be able to like
Grow as a
um
As a participant if you don't
Help me out a little bit
And so then they were like, you know what? Okay. And then I would learn like what my limits are and how to hold my own
and it was
It was like it just leveled the playing field. The only thing that was annoying is that my tits got in the way a lot
I remember I had a guy like accidentally like go for
a
For some grips and he like grabbed me in the boob
And he was like, oh fuck. Sorry. And I'm like, huh get rekt and then I like I like did an inversion and then I just fucked him up
I'm like, I don't give a shit. This isn't
like
It's not like it's a different situation. Like we're sparring. We're just we're just doing whatever
Put his ass inside control real quick
Have person to be like come at me um growing up in school. Nobody wanted to fight me
Because I was one taller than everybody
um
And I it was weird like I have this weird thing where if someone
Like comes at me and starts to like try to argue with me or something. I just laugh at them
And it's probably like a nervous tick of mine, but
It it seems like intimidates people is what I've been told
Because I remember this girl came up to me. She's like, um at work and she's like
One I am not like a gossipy person. I'm not. Um, I don't have the energy. I'm too fucking old for that shit
It's not high school anymore
And she's like, have you been talking shit about me? And I literally started
Hysterically laughing at her. I'm like, who the fuck told you that?
If I had something to say I'd say to your fucking face
And I was pissed because she's my friend and I'm like, why do you think it was because this one dude who um
Had a crush on her was like trying to separate her from us from our friend group
He was a shitty dude
Um
And so and then she said afterwards like she's like it kind of freaked me out
Then I'm like, sorry. Well, like
You didn't have to
The way you approached it. The way you spoke to me was disrespectful. So I'm gonna disrespect you back, you know
If you came out to be like, hey somebody told me that you said something negative about me
Then I'm gonna be like, what? I'm gonna get to the bottom of it. I'm the type of person that like if I hear
Someone
saying something negative
About me or some other. Oh, look at you cleaning in me. Um, me or another person
I like immediately go to nip it in the butt because I'm like we're adults
Fuck it out. Like we're not fucking doing this. It's fucking stupid
We'll be reversal. Yeah, it's part of how wrestling isn't gay. Yeah
Uh, I need gold for that. All right, I'm gonna make another
Another oh, I don't have money
I
What will give me a lot of my gold? Oh, yeah, but
Should go fishing this fishing would get me stuff
It's also cotton because I don't need cotton either
Nope didn't even mean to catch him
I'm desperate need of that wood
Game is like for a moment
Look at me
Oh hi, what's up?
Uh, sure
Yeah, I'll always I'm sorry my cat's food is going off. I
I'll always stand my ground and
If I don't agree with something I will speak my mind
I'm not gonna really bother with these. Oh, they're a cop profiliac like some of you guys
They gain faith when they fall ill while they're about to fall ill. So I'm supposed to be sickly apparently
Then I can literally just
Tell them
Pass out on the ground that's so funny
Yeah, I think like I was
When I was younger I was very much a push over
And I my mom always said that I was a follower and I wasn't a leader
um
Because I would have really bad friends that would like
Take my money and I'd be like, yeah, it's fine or just like I just wouldn't be able to stand it for myself and then
Growing up. I just eventually learned to do so really like working at um
The retail store was a
Very big dose of reality for me because after growing up so sheltered
Um and like
Experiencing the real world with people and like
The drama and all that other shit and I'm like wait a second like I don't even
I don't have to I don't have to have this reaction. I don't have to act this way
I don't have to do this. I don't have to do that. I don't have and I did it was like
Just releasing all that shit and just being like, oh
Wow, and this like the stress off my shoulders
It was very nice. Um, I should probably refine some stuff
Good night. Good night
I have bushes and machines to see. Yeah, of course. Good night. Yeah, that's nine
Probably gonna go see if I can kill the cat and I'll probably go to bed myself
See, can I upgrade? No, I need to wait for that. Oh, you mean the fucking scarecrow
How am I supposed to how am I supposed to fit these motherfuckers?
How much space does he take up? He takes up one
Um
Then I could
Actually
I'm gonna kind of fuck myself but just
Get rid of that
Uh
What we guys are stinking up the place
Perfect
And
Ten of that
That's my cat's food. Take forever. I don't want to go off
Only do the first one
Can I take you a while brother?
Don't know their stone place. I really like I don't usually like like, um
Um
Like management stuff, but I really like
I didn't miss game for some reason. I need money
I still don't have money
I
Need a burp to drop the lurkers. Yeah, no, I know I was gonna be like pretty chill today. So I'm not
Don't worry about that stuff
Just chill kind of just want to like
Hang out, you don't have to talk
Zero I'm sending you out there. You're gonna get some meat. Don't die, please
It's pretty cool. Yeah, we was we were just vibing. We're just hanging out. We're chatting. We're having a good time
No need to rush. No need to be like
Oh
Nobody's talking. I'm content. Just spending time and hanging out with you guys to be honest with you
Like that's I think that's um
That's something
I've
realized I enjoy a lot about like some friendships that I've had is like being able to
Um kind of just hang out with someone and not have to say a word
Like when you just can be comfortable in the silence
Um in a friendship it's a very
Little thing, you know
Oh now we're all right, we're doing pretty well
Friendly fire
Yeah, you just have me in the background as I talk about nothing
Okay, do I have an I'm not gonna actually worry too much about the beds
Um
I'm really just trying I'm just waiting on those stones
I
Hurry up
Do I have enough yet because I want to make the uh
Farmer plot where they collect it so I don't have to worry about it
Excuse me. Oh perfect
Uh
We're just gonna
We're here
Yep
And then we're gonna
Milt
Oh
Fuck uh, I forgot that you have to upgrade
Okay, let me move that back never mind
Uh, we're just gonna move it back to where it was
And then we're gonna upgrade it
Companionable silence is a very far that's just a pretty way to say it. Companionable silence
Having a silence with this court call is always fun
I'm gonna fall asleep in a discord call
Can't imagine it's like to be two with an audience. I don't want to touch for this stick
Oh, yeah, yeah, I don't I don't really get that like why do you do what you do if you don't like your audience
It's always confused me. You're like, oh, I hate my fan base
And like when people say like chat reflects streamer, it's really true you
if you
cultivate
A certain fan bait like if you cultivate or have this sort of certain personality
You're gonna why are you guys fighting? Um
It's gonna reflect on chat and chat's gonna act a certain way
so it only makes sense to
you know
Be the type of person you want to
track
your streams
Or is there a way to like upgrade it so like I don't have to go in collection all the time
Oh so much
I need cauliflower seasoning
I
Say where as cool as you I'm not saying none of that don't get it twisted
I like I want to that's my catchphrase as a
sheebie
Don't get it twisted because I'm wearing shabari ropes
That's why I say it so much because I want it to be my thing. It's every every vtuber has like a phrase
I want that to be my phrase my soon my soon dere
Girlfail dom phrase
Oh
I mean you're doing boomy he's doing around
All right, let's do it wait what do you want kamikaze zombie?
I don't want to find find your fucking brother
We're gonna sacrifice them when we get them
I'm not doing that now. I'm gonna go kill heck it. What the heck it only got my edge
Day girl felt on vtubers. Oh, that's my way. That's what people have been calling me. I don't mind it though. I like it
Hello
Oh
Okay
That was forgiving of the game. Oh fucking hammer. Let's do it. It's hammer time
She's perfect. Wait actually sorry, I've been like checking
Video cannot be long
What the hell it said this song the stuff was
It was copyright free. I fucking hate that
It was just saying my stuff was restricted
copyrighted
Hey, thank you for getting me a little box off my
No, I stuffed up put stuff somewhere
I
Yeah, it said it was
Copyright free royalty free music and it linked to where they got it from that. I was like, I'm like, what the fuck you lied to me
Doesn't matter
I'm not really like super hyper focused on monetization. Although I'm it's mostly just like it's a
As someone who's been a v another vtuber, are you just a content creator on youtube in general?
I've never been able to get monetized
Like or just like be able to be part of the partner product like so that's like it's the title
That's important to me. It's not like the actual like being monetized
But because I'll be like it's just it's a milestone for me because I've never
I've gotten that before
Like the fact that I think
Like I'm like I'm 10k away from 100k views on my channel
Like that just like it literally makes me want to cry because I'm just like holy shit
I never ever thought I would
get
That sort of attention in any way shape or form
Ooh
So it's just really cool to see the fruits of my labor
No, yeah, I appreciate it. Yeah, it's like I also just want the fucking emotes like
Sucks that they don't have anime emotes though
I'm fast
Okay, at least with these I can kill them one time. So I'm like, how am I not?
I'm always sad chopping this fucking tree down
Am I chopping a tree when it's a
But it's a fucking hammer music. Have you ever tried to chop a tree down with a hammer?
But yeah, I I appreciate the support it's been so cool. Um
While I've been here a week like I've said yesterday, it feels like I've been with hanging out with you guys for longer
This feels so right
Oh
Oh, I need 200 I forgot I needed money for that. Um, oh, I will
Can you go away? I'm trying to
If I kill it all of them, I will happen
I'm like super hold on can I say
It's fine
Okay, you don't really do anything to me you just you just whine about it
You look more stream spirit. Oh, thank you. Thank you. I appreciate it
I
Had any more emo ideas
um, you get I don't really
There's like
There's one emo. I like
I know I fucking like me on this channel
And if you ever followed me, I feel I had a really popular emo that was just like me crying
And I used to always be like what the fuck is going on and so I want to get a what the fuck is going on
I also just might get like different stylized emotes
Uh, let's get this wood two times coins
I can just go straight. I might just go straight. Yeah, I'm fine. I'm willing right now
It's finished day eight of 30 days work straight with me. What the hell? Why are you doing that to yourself?
Oh
Yeah, I just want to say thank you for real from the bottom of my
Girlfail dom harp
That you guys look want to watch me and shit. It's really cool
Um, thank you for supporting the girls. Oh, perfect more food. I'm so excited
Ah
Oh, I think you need a different job
Um, but
This feels surreal to be here
And I just can't wait for what
Like
Well, what would be like in like a month?
I'm actually like really nervous about like collabs with other companies because again, I used to like watch them and now
I get to just like hang out with them
Um, and I'm also nervous that like people won't want to hang out with us because
For content
But like I'm happy that like we have like the new girls and I have
some indie friends
Mercy died of old age. No, okay, we're gonna resurrect mercy. Oh wait. No, fuck. I don't have the resurrect thing
Um, we went with the funeral. We'll have a nice funeral for mercy
Unless she gets resurrected
Uh, I kind of like what I have so much of that
Mercy was a hag
Well, you won't see a collab with any superstitious little company for sure
Well, yeah, because that'll be on them. It's up to them like like I can't
Like you probably why don't there's so many stuff here with him. I've seen him like five times
Sorry, I need meat from your followers. Thank you. Also, you should stop bagging up your people. It's kind of fucking weird
um
It's like I can be say so if I want to like
The only thing that's difficult for me
Is like maybe not swearing
But like oh hell I literally that is like glitched. Um
I
Like I can do that
It wouldn't be difficult and then I would just like probably get a fucking different outfit
But like I also don't want to change
Who I am. Oh, I was looking at chat. Um
For somebody just to like me
And like it's mostly as I run into that it's mostly for the um other girls
Like I just I just want us to be successful and I want to go to be happy
My measure success by happiness
Damn, this is actually a kind of cracked thing
Oh, what the fuck I'm like, please don't tell me if I'm glitched
I
Don't be okay. Yeah. Yeah, exactly. Exactly
You guys are right
I
Like I was in a job interview and I said that
And I'm like a measure of my success where the customer's happiness and they like laugh at me because they want me to talk about
metrics, so I'm like, oh, okay
Kind of want to wait
No, cool down. That's gonna be take too long
Hey
What's up, wait a second, uh, I don't trust you guys
Do
Not trust
you guys
I am ending the crowd control because I'm gonna try to beat this boss and I'm gonna go
Yeah, yeah, definitely you have free my expression. She hates us. No, you hate me
You hate me
I don't know I can't I don't know about that
Um
Yeah, I think when people see like how wholesome we are we're just kind of funny and coming from like the whore the whorepo
They'll just kind of be kind of put off by that like just be like confused
Is like wait, they're wholesome and they're actually really fun entertainers and they're really nice people
And
Like like I said, it's not even for me because I I don't care, but I just want
I just want
I might die um girls
Jesus fuck
Maybe I should have left it on because then you guys want to heal me
So many fucking frogs
Oh
I'm locked in
Oh fucking thing
Oh
Missing
It's all right, it's all right. I'm gonna do it again. Well, I think I have to walk you for full say so
I remember I did a stream I played oblivion and
I like tried to be
Say so for this stream and they only last like an hour
That's because I was really trying but like if someone's like, hey, I need you to do this. I'll be like, oh, yeah, sure. I got you
yeah
So you can actually be yourself and go for some persona. Yeah, I feel comfortable. I feel it feels good to be she be
That's gonna be chilly
It's a fucking hammer
I
Did you die is there a please oh, thank god
Thank you. Is there a go to sleep? Okay, uh, where is oh mercy, um
Uh come with me
Although I bet you would want me to harvest for me
We'll have a little funeral for you
What the fuck you just pooped in front of me embarrassed bro, you should be
Okay, I need a building
It's important to like keep up a consistent supply of these motherfuckers otherwise you're fucked
Oh
I'm gonna use go ahead
Oh, yeah, that's right. I can get a shrine flame. Oh, yeah, I need to fucking do that
Need that
Oh
I need fucking money
You guys got any money for me?
Oh, perfect
Oh
I just heard in the stream the scallop is she be wearing I'm in I'm goth. I'm gothic now. Okay. I'm gothic
Goff don't worry about it. My head's also floating around. Don't worry about it. Don't worry about it
Oh my god, we got food a plenty in this piece. Oh look at that. Oh, look at all this food
I can make a hearty meat broth
This is great
I
Wish I could like I wish there was like a farm you could like farm meat besides cannibalism
Oh golden poopy
It's not a phase. It's a lifestyle
Why are you so pissed
Oh
Everybody's so angry
Need some fucking money
Actually
Is that emo shiwi? Yeah, I hate it here. I hate my life
We're emo just because we read my immortal. So it's only fair that we
You know, we're we're gothic
They called us all herbivores. No, we eat meat
Time for a little funeral for mercy
Oh
Look at that bodies
Why is there a duck surrounded by black hearts confused by that
56 what are you we
My age
Oh, look how pretty it is. She was laid to rest
We'll see you on the other side mercy
May your soul cross into Valhalla
Yeah, don't fucking puke guys I just made so much food for you
I
Not great
And
I wish there was like more food options. Let me go fishing
Somebody chop down that tree for me please
I'm sorry Serenity. Let me take your shit. Well literally
Okay
Okay, I could make another outhouse
Should make another farm
Faith I need to build tabernacle. That's what I need to do. I'll do that right here
Right, I'd actually put it where this fucking tree is. I mean when this fucking tree first somebody got distracted
Oh
Perfect right next to the thingy
Get a beautiful grave. Let's go visitor grave
Oh
I'm gonna take whatever that is from a grave. Okay, I forget that I can like summon a demon
um
That's a rare return to the red hearts
Fia, what are you doing?
Emmy
Oh wait, you know what I should do I think if Emmy a different necklace so she lives out here
It's like in her lord
We're emo because you know it's a lifestyle. We're uh
Rewrite my immortal
And we're you can interact with it
Oh cool. Um
And you know if you're on big gothic
My parts represent my soul. Why was there a doc?
Okay
You're buying more seeds
We do we do okay, let's do it
I want to kill a cat
We'll come into the harlot lifestyle
I see
Perfect nice perfect perfect. Okay, that's good. That's good. Oh perfect
We're golden we're golden boys
Perfect setup. Okay
None of you guys can fuck it up. She me goes to dispenser one time
If I I feel like this shares some of the same music as inscriptions
So because there's like a
Um
Under tone when the song first starts that sounds exactly like an inscription track when you fight the trapper and the
The
Other person that's the same person spoiler
You've been ever attacked by a goose. No, I know not to fuck with the geese's the goose's
I think I just turned around like what the fuck? Oh, we did
I forget that I can throw shit
Uh, I'm just gonna go straight wait, no, I'm not gonna try to clear each room. I can only do
I think we're horrible in this piece. Don't be mean to geese. What the hell is it working for some reason
Oh wait, go back. There's a heart go back. No fuck
I hate these things so fucking much
Give me that the heart
Sleeping bag is collapsed god damn it
Like that part the I don't know it sounds like when you fight leshy and he gets the moon out
Oh
Do I want a different now I'm path at least resistance, please
Nice to meet a super nice
Sounds delicious
I have plenty of that some salmon. Fuck you guys up. Don't worry about it
I'm so sorry. I didn't mean it
I like how you think that like you would say something when you do that when you just like kill everybody who was serving
Oh, what the fuck are these
Pops. Oh, this is for the beer
All right
I forget what I have to do before the other rituals
All right, good good
All right, let's kill hack it
What the heck it let's kill hack it
I'm glad is there is no longer exhausted. Bye. Bye
Oh
Freezes time for a short period of time I'm gonna do
This one because I feel like that spreezes for longer. Um, okay, how do I get to the fastest?
Let's have a more change my weapon. I'm fine on that
I
Wish if I had half a spear heart I could fill it up with um
Oh, I'm good. I'm good. I don't need any of that shit. Oh, thank you
You're good. I'm just hanging out. That's fine
Stay hanging out
Oh
Where's the room
This is going to start what the fuck is it up top?
Yeah, sorry, I'm looking at the map
I
Know I'm so dumb sometimes I'm better if I don't have a map
So just go with my heart
Seems it's a quiet right here in the hair and hair colors. Yeah, we're just hanging out
It's okay
Oh, yeah, oh cool, that's cool. I hope he likes it very well
Yeah, call the lamb is so good. I love calling lamb. It's just fun. Oh, no, what am I doing?
All right, and skip
Why are they hopping in?
Oh
No, oh wait, I'm gonna do this. No, what the fuck didn't do anything
What the hell
I'm supposed to freeze enemies and then it frees them
I'm gonna be so
Oh
Oh, thank you so much good timing
Thank you so much for the support trick. Oh, I see you you're not into bunny girls. Oh
Oh
Yeah, my cats are pretty cool pretty pretty damn awesome
All right cat treats for the win honestly, oh, I am more of a little hunter right now my hands are like
Oh
Oh, what's up? I wanted these bones
We fucking killed a heck it what the heck it
the hecky
I enjoyed watching you destroy heck it
But arrogance was always destined to be her undoing
Yeah, my face crusade against the old faith warms my cold unbeating heart
I'll be glad you're having a good night
Do I get the sex update now do I get the sex update?
I
Love the confetti
Amy's no longer a demon
What I see do I gotta put you in fucking jail? Oh my god, I always gotta jail her
You might have to get those propaganda speakers
Oh
Look at this look we're thriving over here
I'm gonna say thriving. I mean sure
Oh
I have to feed the masses
Are you sick
I wish they would just like go heal themselves poor Misma
Damn brat. I know she always has to be corrected
He's always looking to be corrected
I
Me I'm sending you out
Why would you die? Why is there a 50-50 chance? Oh, it's cuz she's exhausted. Okay, nevermind
Um, everybody else is kind of too lovable level
Strani is elderly. No, Strani
Strani
Just fucking laughing and I see what the Amy go to bed wake up. Don't get mad
Go to sleep you have a bed
I
Make them younger I can give them a thing to
Make them live longer. I think there is a way to make like I'm younger again to be honest with you
Oh, sorry, didn't mean to interrupt you. Whatever the hell your name is
Okay
Wow, we eating good today everybody come I must preach a new doctrine on TV
And grandma grandma strani grandma strani
Let's do
Work work work work work
um
I
Will make the mark 10 times or ever two days
An intent, you know, it's moron
Yeah, fuck you guys you're getting intimidated
Yeah, of course good night
Bye
Nice long stream nice long day hanging out with the with the boys the girls with the homies
I
Just crying below I'm like, I'm fine
Mean I'm so intimidating
I'm the most intimidating
Whatever has been
I'm so tired
I'm starting to be delirious
What is happening
Hello, oh, it's a sexy update guys, it's a sexy update
Holy shit, it's a sexy update
Hey
Brown bearer how wonderful to finally speak you've come far
further than they know
Crown bearer judge of what is right and wrong. Absolutely is your word their duty is to follow
They offer you a loyalty devotion. It is not enough. I can feel a sin seep from myself
Obviously to gather it to use it. I don't know. I'm Sean Connery lead them into poverty. He's a shinking modern viral reputation
Sinners your absolve them exculpate them deliver them and give you the tools for the town
Sex update sex update sex update
I'll never be off
You can now know how sinful a follower has been once they've sinned enough to become consumed by it
So all these fellow chargers soon from my temple. Yeah
cool
I like how it's a snake because like very much a nod to like adam and eve. Oh shit
I feel like you're hearing things
Uh
Havoc and violence or no, we're gonna be lost whole
No, I wasn't there's a sexy update. We're all gonna dance naked
Or I could have been like we're disrespect your surroundings, but like
Either one would have been on on cue. Yeah, I'd be naked. You want to see?
Get naked
Oh
My god, whoa, it'd be sneaky
I can select the Mayflower leader, uh, it's gonna be strongy duh
Oh my god, she's not wearing a shirt
Oh
The sin grew within me I am for more to be consumed
But you have granted me redemption and now I am in peace again. Thank you
Anytime strongy
Oh shit, I forgot all about all this
Oh
Look at their butts. I know they're so cute little booty cheeks
Let's fucking go
Cool
All right, I'm pressing accept
So fun
The sin stuff is like I haven't played too much fences and little fuss updates so
That'll be cool
Look at everybody's dancing around naked and happy having a great time
No
No strongy
Oh
She literally she had she had one last straw and then she fucking died. Oh man
Uh, I'm gonna you ain't put you right there for a moment
I
Don't know any god song scum songs, but I want to say a few words. Hold on
Oh
Strongy was a real one
I loved her deeply she was the best mom that I could ever ask for
She will go and God's grace
Will thrive in the heavens
Farewell mother
Oh
Sad imagine I just exhumed her body we ate her that'd be so fucking crazy a little bit. I'm kidding. I'm not gonna do that
I don't think I can
All right, we'll have we'll have a funeral for strongy. Oh my god. Why is it so dirty?
Everybody's fucking vomiting everywhere
How household
I
Guess nobody's gonna fucking do their work because they're all ninky running around. Oh glowing poopy
Cannibal
Oh
Music is so good in this game
I'm all prancing excitedly. What's up?
Okay, Zara Zara says she wants to go on a mission
Um, you can
Get some meat, please don't fucking die
I'm already so happy and naky and reading books. This is great. I'm so happy for us
What's up
Oh
It's funny because like some people are naky and some people aren't
This is what I mean. I'm like, oh, I'm gonna end soon. I'm like, wait, I gotta do this first
I
Make sure you have your ppe glasses still to boost the heart out erm, she we I think there's something on your chest
Fuck
Why'd you do that?
I was rude
How dare you
Can't believe you've done this
Fuck I can't believe we've done this
I think she was an illusion
I don't have enough flowers god damn it
Oh
I want to hold the thing for strongy. All right. Um, I see just fucking in the thing. I see stop being bad
She's the baddest of mom
You want to dance, baby?
You want to dance, baby
All right
Cool
What? Oh, wait. No, I need to defeat flinky at knuckle bones and then
Fortnight dances away
I unironically do the orange justice dance what I did
This is this is really good, you know
All right here to fuck people up
Alrighty
All right flinky dinky malinky
All right
Yeah, absolutely fucked fuck
I remember I played
and
He managed to like weirdly
Because I forget how it works
Like this there's like one bot that like does something super fucking weird when you're forcing them. Oh my god, rena
Jesus Christ, you scared the shit out of me
Uh
Reena you're in the way
I'm stunk
Wait, is this yachtsy? Is this what yachtsy is?
Is yachtsy knuckle bones because I never played yachtsy
I can hear Reena purring
What are you doing in my swamp? Why are you fucking being shit at the game? I don't understand
You're absolutely mugged, bro
Yeah
What I suppose you better take this
Oh, thanks
What is that? Oh
Then you don't poison
I understand will coming from a snake. You want to you want to dance?
Give me out of here
Reena you can't land my hand when I'm using it to play video games
Terrible sacked bum
Perfect name
All right, we're gonna save
We're a good spot
I hope you like stream today. It was fun
um
It's cool. Do it reading my immortal and just playing a little bit uh
A little bit uh called the lamb
And I'm gonna send you over to strone because she's still fucking streaming the absolute lunatic
Anonymous tips three dollars. Thank you. Thanks for both stream she be also nice hoodie bro. Yeah, right. My head is pretty flat
Thank you for the the tip
It was fun. It was a nice day today. Thank you for spending your time with me
I hope you have a good night
Oh
I genuinely don't know like when she's I don't like like I don't know
I don't think shawty sleeps at all
Because she wakes up. No, she doesn't wake up. She's just alive. She's just there
And then she does so much stuff
And she streams and she does more stuff. I don't think she sleeps
I think she's just forever awake. She just has a superpower of being awake all the time
All right
Bye guys, I don't know what the chat would do
Fuckin
I'm gone. I think that's what it is
Oh, there you guys are
I'm starting to party too hard. It's like showing like old messages. It's funny
It has to play catch up
Uh
Thank you guys so much for the support. It's been awesome week
First week with you guys. Can't wait for this week. Can't wait for the um collab
So we have a power for power watch simulator
I got um
I think I have another craps treasure tomorrow that I'm playing
Yeah
You try don't let them out
So